i'm going to make a case to you today
why i believe firing the bottom 10
of every single industry not just
company every single industry military
cops teachers firefighters realtors loan
officers
amazon walmart it doesn't matter what it
is if you fire the bottom 10
of every single industry the economy
will get better and people will actually
be more fulfilled and happy let me make
my argument to you why i believe that's
the case watch this
you ever been in a relationship where
say you're dating somebody for two years
and you're like
this is not going to go anywhere i'm not
going to marry this person we're not
going to be together for 10 years but
we're so comfortable
and i'm scared to call the the breakup
i'm scared to break up with her right
i'm scared to break up with him
and then one day you get that random
text or the phone call you know what the
phone call is what text that is right
it's like
hey yeah we need to talk you're like
what do you mean we need to talk what
are you doing later on tonight we need
to talk
and you're like okay cool we can talk so
you go meet her
and or he meets you and says you know
you have to realize baby i love you so
much
and you already know where this is going
it's been the last one of my best two
years of my life
but i just don't think this is going
anywhere and and
it's not you honestly it's me it's not
it's not you at all it's totally me and
i
i just think i just think we have to go
our separate ways i don't i don't know
if i strengthen you and i don't know if
you're happy being with me
but no i want to be with you know the
whole you you don't understand
you okay so if you know what i'm talking
about and then six months later you're
like man i'm so glad he broke up with me
it was so great i couldn't do it i'm
glad he did it i'm so glad she broke up
with me
i couldn't do it she did i'm so glad she
did let me go back to the firing part
you know what happens when you fire some
people from their job or sometimes
apartment like i had a guy that was
working with a
department with us for four and a half
years i'm sitting there every day
i would ask his director why do we have
him here
he sucks at his job we finally
fired him from that job we moved him
over he made four times the money he was
making at that job
when he simply got fired from that job
went to a different place
you fire a cop there are a lot of people
that are cops or teachers because their
parents were cops
because traditionally they want to be
cops or traditionally they want to be in
you know whatever job it is but they
don't want to do that they're just doing
it because of somebody else they're
being a cop because their friends are
cop they're doing
whatever because of somebody else and
then all of a sudden they're like no
longer a cop anymore no longer a
teacher anymore and you sit there and
you say what should i do now that cop
becomes a realtor he excels goes and
wins at the highest level he's like man
i'm so glad the fire department
the police department fired me you know
man i'm so glad being a teacher i was
not a good teacher man i can't believe i
was a teacher i'm terrible as a teacher
but man i make one hell of a cop
do you see the difference there man i
got to tell you i was a terrible
coach but man i make such a good
project manager when it comes down to at
it i love what i'm doing right now
so this isn't the concept of firing
people like you're
fired this isn't that like you're fired
this is the whole idea of
how many people today are in positions
that is not the position for them
you make one shift to a different
department they excel
just because their current position
doesn't bring out their strengths
that they have you can make one shift
give them a better opportunity in a
different place
or simply fire everybody because some
people just are not good at their job
teachers i don't believe all teachers
are good teachers i think there's a
bottom ten percent of teachers should be
fired
for them to realize man i can't do this
anymore and i let them go do something
else
by the way here's one other thing to be
thinking about if we fire the bottom 10
every year guess what people don't want
to be in they don't want to be in the
bottom 10 percent
so they fight to be in the top 50
percent that means they may have been a
70 percent
and they go up into 50 and they move up
because
they don't want to get fired so it even
makes people offer better customer
service better service better effort
improving but get better with people in
every possible way
because they know when december 31st
comes the bottom 10
is getting fired and you do not want to
be in the bottom 10 percent fyi
i'm very aware that about 10 of you are
not going to like this video
hence you're the bottom 10 percent this
is unfair
why patrick's like such and such all he
wants to do is fire people let's fire
pat and unsubscribe i get it by the way
you want to fire some of the channels
you're subscribed to
you ought to fire some of the people you
follow there's a firing going on in
friends
and people you hang out with every year
this ought to be taken
place to allow
new you know things to grow within your
life and new people to grow
within different industries i'm not
expecting 100 of you guys to like this
matter of fact i think for every hundred
one of you that puts a thumbs up
i think ten of you is gonna put a thumbs
down so if you don't like it put a
thumbs up if you like it put a thumbs up
and whether you love it press the
subscribe button if you haven't already
but i got another video for you
i did a video years ago titled how to
fire someone
you may agree with you may not agree
with the matter mike i may even watch it
i might not agree to of to the points
that i did when i did that because i've
changed the way i fire people
but i want you to watch this video i
think there's a couple points in it that
you're going to like
from how to fire someone if you've never
watched this
click over here to watch the video on
how to fire someone take care everybody
have a great week